I've been in your Shadow for
hours but since nothing pathetic
I asked for an equal and this is what
you find sir perhaps a new hunting ground
light the fires
the great hunt begins
you have no idea
triangulating position Target located at Harlem
Fish Market all teams converge lizards across
the river I'm not gonna make it in time miles the
hunters track Connors to the Harlem fish market
dessert sounds like Kraven's checking off we don't
have much time move I'll boot up and see you there
they got here fast
can't let them find Connors
Ganke get behind me
it's just his skin doesn't
that mean he's getting bigger
hungrier too
oh amen new threats the building's swarming with
Hunters any sign of Connors uh
yeah ganke's tracking him hey Mr Parker
but the data isn't complete
me neither I don't even have a stomach so
let's go
East River is not a river but in
fact the saltwater tidal flat but
Spiderman is fighting on right now everybody
help the door vote right I've
got the metal murder bird
I warned you about going after
Connors now this is on you
clouds that all you got
Spider-Man hang on
come on let's go
hold on
everyone take cover
I saved the tracker
let's go man before he gets too far no he's
mine you sure it's got big teeth so do I
um he's not normally like that
right no he's never like that
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie Marvel just
dropped the Spider-Man 2 trailer there's a whole
bunch of big reveals especially Spider-Man wearing
the Venom symbiote suit there's a whole bunch of
stuff in here obviously big coincidence that
Kraven is going to be one of the main villains
and there's a Kraven the hunter movie coming out
with Aaron Taylor Johnson later this year the game
is coming out around the same time that's what
we call Synergy right there if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos I'll give away copies when they do
release it later this year too just starting at
the beginning of the trailer obviously the big
reveal is that Kraven the hunter is going to be
the main villain and he comes to New York City
to start his great hunt like he comes for his
hunting grounds because they're just way more
heroes and villains anti-heroes for him to take
down the events of the game are meant to pick up
after the events of the Spider-Man Miles Morales
game and obviously a couple years after the events
of the first game but what they don't explain
is that when they pick up six months later in
New York City Peter Parker already has the Venom
symbiote suit so you're wondering what happened to
Harry Osborne who had the Venom symbiote before
him Norman Osborne will be green Goblin at some
point either during this game or they'll tease him
at the end for Spider-Man 3 because he'll probably
be a third game pretty easy to assume they'll
probably explain that in some flashback because
it sounds like you'll start the game in that six
months later timeline where he already has this
symbiote or maybe there'll be some quick moment
at the beginning where it explains how he gets
the Symbiote but when Kraven is selecting New York
City as his hunting grounds and he looks at the
pad they reveal most of the other characters that
are gonna appear now there's other characters that
they don't reveal like Genki is a big character
and he's not on the readout here but at least the
other ones that they show in this moment are Black
Cat Prowler wraith Tombstone Taskmaster Kingpin
meaning he's coming back they locked him up at the
beginning of the first game shocker then obviously
the lizard and when the action picks up six months
later in Queens it looks like what's happening is
at Spider-Man's house they come looking for Kurt
Connor's lizard who's broken out of his house and
run to the docks with Spider-Man busting out of
his basement with the Symbiote on coming after
Kraven's people yelling at them to stay off of him
and you can see he's gone super aggro which Miles
Morales remarks on later like no he's never
like that and that's meant to be right out of
the comics and you've seen Spider-Man 3 with Toby
Maguire you've seen all the other symbiote stories
it drives them way darker way more hardcore you
want forgiveness get religion what's going on
here but the whole idea here is that he's trying
to protect Kurt Connor's lizard because it sounds
like he's dying like he says that he's dying and
we're the only ones that can save him but also in
addition to that Kraven has selected him to kill
him as one of his next targets so even though
he's lost control by transforming into lizard
gone completely crazy Spider-Man is trying to
help him with Miles Morales help when he calls
miles you notice that he's using the Drone which
looks like it's based on vulture Tech like it's
a vulture looking type of drone but genki's voice
is speaking through it the other big thing too is
that Spider-Man across the spider versus coming
out in the next couple of weeks and a lot of the
PS4 Spider-Man characters are characters during
that movie like because it's a big Multiverse
movie they canonize both Spider-Man PS4 like
this version of Spider-Man and this version of
Miles Morales as well as spider cat to the events
of that movie and when Peter Parker joins them at
the Docks miles reacts to the symbiote-like new
threads as if he's seeing it for the first time
and he knows nothing about what's going on with
it this whole water-based fight just feels like
it's meant to be a Godzilla in a Jaws reference
with I'm chasing lizard as he swims through the
water and him almost biting Miles Morales in half
until he uses his camouflage ability to hide
love the reference to Kraven's gunship being
a metal murderbird then we get that cool attack
scene of Spider-Man telling Miles Morales that he
can handle lizard on his own because he has big
teeth too like big venom jaws and Miles sounding
like he's kind of worried talking to geeky like
he's never been like that before never been that
hardcore like I said I think this is meant to be
pretty early in the game I'm sure at some point
they'll tease Norman Osborne Green Goblin and
they'll have to explain somehow what happened
to Harry Osborne and how the Venom symbiote
passed to Peter Parker because Peter Parker
didn't know that Harry had the Venom symbiote
during the events of the first game that was
meant to be a post-creditscene tag revealed that
Norman Osborne had given it to Harry but that was
only to cure the illness that he had Tony Todd
is doing the voice of the Venom character and it
obviously doesn't sound like Peter Parker
using Venom voice with Tony Todd's voice
I am we are Venom
so at some point they have to explain this other
version of Venom the only other thing they don't
really touch on here is the idea of the raft just
holds a lot of Spider-Man's villains so they might
travel back there at some point but it sounds
like based on all the targets that Kraven selects
a bunch of them already roaming free around New
York City obviously it'll be a much bigger game
than the first Spider-Man PS4 game and Spider-Man
Miles Morales both of those games were amazing so
I'm sure this one will be off the chain everybody
posts all your predictions in the comments below
are there's any questions you have about the
footage that they did show us I'm supposed to
see Spider-Man across the spider verse tonight
but I won't be able to post my review until the
embargoes up so as soon as they let us I will
post my review of that but it looks like it's
going to be a really awesome movie because the
game's not coming out till fall they'll wait till
a little bit later to release another trailer
but like I said because they're releasing the
Kraven the hunter movie around the same time
this game is coming out just expect there to
be a lot of cross promotion going on Kraven in the
video games and Kraven in the movies the only big
difference is that the Aaron Taylor-Johnson
Kraven movie the Sony and Marvel are making
is going to be a really hardcore R-rated movie
one of the first ones that Sony has done in a
while I kind of wish the Venom movies were
rated R2 they released a trailer for that
at Cinema con I've already done a video
for it so you can click here to learn all
about that and click here for my brand new
secret Invasion trailer video thank you so
much for watching everyone stays safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!